i saw my car to be able to sort of
afford things and invest into starting
the business but i look back and think
well what a great decision your strategy
has been in property quite
unconventional tony slapped me yeah he
said what are you doing but what you're
doing which is really clever is you're
charging the investor before you've even
got the deal how much on average are you
talking to find somebody a deal
the party is big enough for everybody
[Music]
so callum thanks for coming to my house
and congratulations on what you've done
your
strategy has been in property quite
unconventional because you've not just
bought a house rented it out you've been
controlling properties packaging and
selling properties why don't you just
talk to me about
what made you get into property and and
how you got started so originally sort
of six months prior to meeting yourself
i actually did do the conventional thing
i bought a property um through saving up
a deposit bought with a friend of mine
run down property that was sort of the
avenue that was my interest and it just
spiked it so from then on i sort of
looked into yourself looked into
training and discovered rent to rent so
that was sort of my opening packaging
deals how simple that is quick cash flow
which funds sort of the rent to rent
side of it yeah so the house that you
bought then that was how long ago was
that
a year ago just over a year was it your
first property investment yeah so how
much you pay for it
360. and how much you renting it for
when obviously so i lived there in that
property so we did it up
right through that so it was our first
home yeah first-time buyers
um two of us did it
added some value to it we're still
living in it um should be selling this
sort of next year cool but very
conventional and it's very slow which is
not a bad thing yeah but people don't
realize this if you want to buy a house
and rent it out or buy a house and do it
up or whatever it takes six months just
to buy it yeah it's super slow so it's
all good having slowpan but you do need
in my opinion if you want to make money
in property i think you need fast pound
property is a business so you want to be
making quick cash and then building the
slow stuff
alongside that yeah so um what did you
think when you first heard about
rent to rent when you heard about deal
packaging what were you all kind of
thoughts yeah skeptical i've never heard
of it just like anybody i think you
should be um a bit of caution around it
so got myself cleared up on all of it um
and just went in just got involved yeah
weighed up the risk it's not that risky
is it they just went for the first one i
think when you like get the keys for the
unit you've just committed to paying the
rent for something um is it actually
going to work and we listed the property
straight away in the condition it was in
so the agreement we had we're going to
add a lot of value to it through our
time
and it was just getting bookings in the
condition it wasn't we couldn't believe
it and so we were bumping up the nightly
rate just thinking we're losing all the
good dates here yeah but it was just
yeah overwhelming just how easy it
worked and where was this property in
bristol yeah central bristol and how
much rent did you agree to pay to the
landlord 1300 a month and what is it so
it's a two bed mason there what did the
landlord say to you when you said to him
i want to rent it i want to pay 1300.
but i'm not going to be living there i'm
going to be putting clients in it on
shorts they let's like was the landlord
skeptical was he unsure or was he happy
as long as you guys went no so this was
really really easy so we went through
all the no's and those and those knows
the state agents go into all the views
it wasn't working literally we walked in
and she was already listening on airbnb
but it was too much hassle for her to
manage it um so she just wanted someone
a tenant in for a longer period of time
and so helped me propose what she was
already doing she said i'll crack on as
long as i get my rent every month
and stuff like that and then we just
sort of went on well we're going to add
value to it because obviously we wanted
to increase the nightly rate and stuff
like that and she was ah that's amazing
so it was like the easiest negotiation
you've ever had to do well how does she
feel though now because how much profit
are you making on that property uh about
1500. so how does she feel i mean she
might not care but knowing that you're
making a grand to 1500 a month profit on
her property
is she not like resentful about that
just i guess the situation she's in is
paying for that she's already got the
asset god knows what the mortgage is on
it probably very minimal if there is one
any problems that because an older flat
problems do
happen and we just take care of it all
so she's we sort of catch up every now
and again and she's over the moon what
would you have done
if after a couple of months your
bookings weren't really
coming in the way you thought you
weren't making any profit are you tied
into a long-term contract no not at all
so but this is when i was on about the
wrist side of it we weighed up all the
risks like worst case scenario what's
going to happen um but yeah we
structured all those brake clauses in
there
and protects her side of it as well so
we knew what what the worst case it
wasn't going to book up what we'd have
to pay
to activate the brake clause right and
go from there but i mean there's other
avenues you could just get a normal
tenant back in which would pay the rent
if we couldn't get out if depending on
what the contract was so yeah just
wasn't that risky at all really what
about another thing that people might be
worried about is
that they take on a rental rent and it's
loads of hassle and loads of work i know
you've got a very demanding full-time
job which you're still working in
in aviation yeah aviation assurance in
comparison to other people is quite easy
from my perspective family side of
things as well so i only do sort of 40
hours a week it's flexible working um
work from home so i can sort of finish a
job and then straight on to property
side of it there's no commuting there's
no sort of it's not a traditional nine
to five so yeah that side of it i'm able
to but you've got like i mean
where was your lightest rent event was
that what was that
yeah and what's the story with that one
is that same kind of no so that one was
through an agent um we actually this
conversation was happening before the
original one back in february um it's
back and forth back and forth i viewed
it i think it was on boxing day and so
it took forever to actually get the keys
and they sort of dropped his first name
in one of the emails and so i just
looked at the build and i knew someone
because it was
an old traditional building in clifton
four stories for a while look it up it
was originally an auction so i just
stalked the hell out of this landlord
found him um he had three registered
companies on company's house sent a
letter to each one to his accountant
literally a week later he phoned me up
and he was like thank god you reached
out to me directly and so we just
created our own contract he paid the
estate agents the fee still um and yeah
we've just built a really good
relationship that's a great thing as
well sometimes when the agents have been
really difficult if you cut the agent
out yeah but then once you've cut the
agent out go back to them give them
their fee don't tell them what you're
going to do show them what you just did
and then they go oh well i've got a few
more people like that and then suddenly
you've kind of got a relationship as
well well that's exactly they've got a
hefty cost of voucher and they were
laughing so and now we're in good
communication with them and i've got a
really good relationship with the
landlord with that property does that
also is that making good profit yeah
again sort of just under 1500 but we've
just locked in five month booking on
that one so i sort of want to experiment
from getting away from the two three
nighters to month bookings yeah i've got
a guy in for a month at the moment and
then bang we had one a request come in
for five months five months yeah who is
this person are they are they a
relocator or yeah so we were targeting
relocators and we've got a couple in
from the philippines at the moment um
and there's a small family coming over
from thailand which are looking to
relocate to bristol and you've also
actively been packaging and selling
deals yeah what kind of deals have you
been selling rental rents but then
recently you had a bit of a change of
plan with that yeah
stop it certainly slapped me yeah he
said what are you doing um so i still
still do both both sides of it um but at
the time i had two renovations going on
i couldn't physically take on any more
unless i was paying someone to do it so
it's a good good idea just cash flow so
how many deals have you sold in the last
few months i've sold four deals over
sort of staggering months um
and changed it all sort of recently that
we just take on bespoke clients so we
take on two people a month now yeah
and we want money up front because it's
been such a time wasting exercise before
where i found the deal and the deal has
fallen through
because they've they're unsure about it
and i've literally gone to them well
i've got one a couple of roads away i'm
making this money
and they still aren't confident so just
time wasting so i think money up front
12 weeks and we work with them so we
didn't just give them the deal we they
we helped them get up and running
because they wanted to run it and manage
it themselves yeah so you always get
even issues so
just what's that me whenever i think
bespoke is such a good idea because as
you said with when you with properties
if you've negotiated a good deal as soon
as your offer is accepted whether it be
on a rent to rent a hmo whatever it is
they want to get it wrapped up quickly
and then if you're dealing with
investors that are sort of oh think
about it give me a couple of weeks give
me a couple of days it's like well you
kind of need to act quickly so what
you're doing which is really clever is
you're charging the investor before
you've even got the deal but you're
telling them that up front you're saying
look
give me x amount of money i'll then go
and find you the deal yeah and then you
can pay the difference which is bespoke
deal sourcing how much on average are
you talking to find somebody a deal just
two and a half to three thousand that's
braille
absolutely brilliant the other side of
it for me is the timeline so i've got
time to do and grow my rent to usa
side of it which i was saying to tony
because he said don't sacrifice your
time on becoming a saucer if your goal
is to grow your service accommodation
business so now i can do both and i know
i've got a bit of time to play with but
i'm also going to find the right deal
for them so question how i know you've
made the money back now just from deal
sourcing you've made money from the
academy back yeah but how did you
justify especially when you're a little
bit unsure about rent to rent a little
bit skeptical hadn't done any creative
deals like before how did you justify
investing so much money into your
personal education and mentorship
how did you justify that i don't know it
was a tough one so
it was sort of a staggered approach um
sort of did a course with yourself like
sort of tested the water and then went
in um in the deep end for me i saw my
car to be able to sort of afford things
like that and invest into starting the
business but yeah i look back i don't
know i can't remember the conversation i
had with myself but i look back and
think well what a great decision because
what i know and it's not just what you
learn from yourself it's the people you
meet and that's what you do on a daily
basis the people i text every day are on
the phones every week like doing similar
things changing that environment you're
in
is is the main benefit i've found from
that and i do it all the time now is
like
i would question it but if there's sort
of mentorship that someone's offering or
there's other training i'd even question
it now i don't i don't see why and i
guess everyone does and that's why
there's
the difference you can choose not to do
it and stay in a sort of traditional job
where you can make it and it was a
bloody big risk for me yeah it was yeah
well yeah anybody yeah did you say you
had to sell your car yes i still i
haven't bought a new one yet so i just
what are you driving are you losing
something no i shared my mistake okay
did it that way yeah again what's the
risk do i need a car work from home yeah
so if i spend this money and it's gone i
don't know but yeah know i mean i i
generally tell people don't invest
don't invest money that it would [ __ ]
you if you lost it yeah so if you're
about to whether it be in training or on
a rent to rent or on a property if it
goes badly it doesn't work out worst
case if you're then going to be
financially crippled and you're going to
lose everything then maybe don't do it
yeah but if the best case is i'm going
to become financially free it's going to
change my life and the worst case is
ah well i have to share my mrs carr for
a year or two well i save up the money
again it's not gonna kill you as it
happens it's worked out but it's also
about you know you create your own
destiny it's not even if you join a
course or join the academy no one's
gonna ever do the work for you
you're gonna have training and mentoring
and opportunities but ultimately you
need to be prepared am i committed to
putting the time in which you you've
done you've put the time in it is worth
well that's it and you get people that
invest in it invest in training and you
can learn everything but it's what you
do you walk out the door when you're by
yourself yeah or who you choose to
surround yourself with is it's how you
keep pushing you need both don't you
need to put in the time and an energy
into it but you also need to know what
you're doing and some people spend loads
of time and energy but they haven't got
the knowledge and they're just motivated
idiots running around doing doing the
wrong things so you need you need the
knowledge but you also need the action
and commitment what would you say has
been
the
hardest aspect of the business at the
moment have there been any times where
you thought man i want to quit
yeah i think when you get the first
well the first couple for me and this
sort of turnover guests and the problems
because you do get problems and social
media and stuff i've tried to sort of
publicize quite a lot of it because i
think you change your audience and with
the honesty that you're providing but
yeah we get problems like i had a phone
call on the way here that i think the
shower or something's leaking at one of
the apartments and it's just you just
but when i was first started it was just
sort of back to back everything was
going wrong it seemed like um i had the
first one live i was renovating the
second one it was going sort of over the
time i've allocated um had neighbor
issues like everybody goes through it
but it's just pushing through it and i
mean touch wood everything's
everything's going fine now and even
problems do creep up you just you've got
the guys in place yeah you build a team
around you and just how can you go check
this out for me yeah and i think being
an entrepreneur and by very definition
an entrepreneur is someone that solves
problems yeah and if you're you know
unable or you're afraid to have to have
problems in your life then maybe you are
better off just having a job and you
know that's that but if you want to make
a lot of money and solve a lot of
problems it's going to come with
headaches but you grow through it don't
you yeah and every time you have a
problem and once you deal with that
problem you know you book a mentoring
call or whatever it is and you find the
answer because there's always someone
else that's had the same problem you
solve the problem you're like oh now i
know how to deal with that and you
become better and richer and a better
businessman what is your strongest
reason because going through all these
problems investing all this money and
time it it's now paid off you know you
do really well what's your re what
what's the thing that keeps you going
through the tough days i think for me it
was sort of when in lockdown um like i
said so i worked from home predominantly
anyway so it wasn't sort of a lot of
interaction um i just sort of lost that
fulfillment from the job sort of the
whole thing of sort of working for
someone else my parents have both
started their own company um so i've
been brought up in that environment and
i just
sort of grown myself out of it and when
we got that property and so we did like
i said all the renovation ourselves and
sort of just spent the amount of hours
we spent there and like loving it
there's no point like really getting
tired for me
um and i thought well this this is
somewhere i could sort of proceed and go
forward with and that's what it was so
it just went from there and the
satisfaction of sort of
i don't know like that five month
booking like
that pain that we were talking about of
like neighbor problems leaks and then
bang you get that and you think well
that's three for rent to rent that
fundraiser for that one booking you can
just scale up
massively off of that and it's just like
yeah this is the reason i'm doing it
this is my company
what has it been like
what's your experience with the academy
being like working with me
yeah it's with other training
back-to-back um
like i said and but then when you sort
of you've done the training and trying
to keep it up like sort of it's quite
easy to drop back down into sort of the
normal sort of routine life but i mean
like jumping on the course of you guys i
mean
the whole thing of doing the course is
you meet people so they've got the same
drive as you they want to achieve the
same thing so you just sort of create
your own sort of environment yeah and
like i keep saying that was the best
thing that came from it is sort of if
you're having a shitty day you can just
phone up someone um and they're probably
having a really good day and they pick
you back up and voice first so you work
as one big team um so yeah that was that
was the best really important i think to
be around people that will pull you up
because environment is stronger than
willpower yeah and when you are having a
bit of a hard day if you've got someone
that can pull you up that's just so so
so essential what would be your best
piece of advice to somebody wanting to
get into property that's maybe new to
packaging deals and rent to rent what
would be your best advice
i think just calculate the risk so and
then just go for it and if it is
feasible just go for it and if it's
i don't know if you can't do the courses
or if you can't do certain things but
instead of just saying sort of i can't
do it how can i do it and if it's the
financial side of it office time side of
it work to your powers if you've got a
partner can you sort of balance the kids
or can you get an additional job to pay
for that in the short term i think just
calculate the risk and go for it because
it might be a hard year 18 months but
after that you can then quit that job or
release more time so you then can just
scale up and i think if if you're not
prepared to if you do now what people
aren't prepared to do
then you're going to be able to live in
a year's time like they'd never dream of
yeah and it's about you know doing the
thing putting the work in now um and
preparing yeah that's it the whole risk
thing it just goes on it's like buying
properties like the recession and things
like that when's a good time to buy a
property like there never is yeah first
is brexit yeah then it's section 24 tax
now tenant eviction bans covered
potential recession there's always going
to be a problem yeah or a reason what
what makes people scared and what makes
people afraid to actually get go out
there but the truth is we create our own
economies and there's always
there's always ways to make money in
property whether the market's going up
or whether it's going down yeah rising
build costs and stuff like that like
join me like the the money i'm now
earning from rent to rent i'm not
worried about sort of my personal life
it's quite an easy fix for people that
are in that situation and now i'm almost
like looking forward to it i can
capitalize off of things like this like
there's going to be flats available
people are going to be moving out it's
going to be bits and bobs going on
people that have sort of paid over the
moon for
a property which they can no longer
afford i mean there's people that have
over leveraged themselves yeah which
is it's horrible in a way but it's just
it's the way it works are you all
friends and family girlfriend what do
they think of the fact that how well
you've done in such a short space of
time they're over the moon so again i
was really lucky that i think people
sort of get struggles where people doubt
their decisions um but my sort of
environment girlfriend mum and dad they
just sort of pushed me on they never
questioned it if it was my decision they
would have known i thought through it um
and it's the right one to make and even
if it wasn't i would have got positive
out of it in some way so that's really
important so often i meet people and
they say i really want to get into
property and i want to go really go for
it but my family and my friends are
telling me to not do it or telling me to
be careful or telling me this and i'm
thinking well
you're going to be so resentful when
you're 70 years old
and you and you're just there with
nothing thinking damn why did i listen
to dave down the pub
you've got to you've got to take
responsibility for your own life and
that's exactly what you've done and you
know huge respect so what's next
so
back to the landlord that i built a
really good relationship with um we're
actually going into business so we've
just secured
um
like a really run down property in
central bristol again so he's purchased
it off auction he loves doing all that
side of it and we just had a phone call
and he just said do you have a build
team because i should because i would be
traveling my build team from london all
the way up there'd be stay in there and
in the property what's been renovated
and i said well yeah i've got build team
so i'm working with one of the builders
from the academy that i've met we're
going to be renovating it and then he's
going to give us all the flats free
studio flats um
on a discounted rate and then obviously
i'll just split them with
the builder that i've met off the power
team and he's obviously going to get
paid to do the renovation as well says
wow
the party is big enough for everybody
and so that's that's that side of it and
then
the money i'm earning and just saving
from rent to rent so i'm going to be
looking to get um me and partner going
to go and get a property sort of 100
grand somewhere either up north or
swansea something like that and sort of
build that side of it incredible so
you're using the cash flow from the rent
to rent
to dump into building your own yeah
flips and bis and all of that yeah
my massive respect and thank you for
coming on the show and sharing and
inspiring people to what was it that
made you agree to come on the show yeah
i think pushing me
no like i said i didn't want to come on
i didn't want to i wanted to build up um
sort of more reputation for myself what
i've achieved um but i think it's just
documenting it it's just sharing what
i've learned yeah i'm willing to take
that risk showing with the risk i've
taken people in different situations i
think some people it's almost selfish to
be like i don't want to come and share
what i'm doing because i don't feel
already i want to be a millionaire first
it's like well just just just document
what you're doing yes five people you
know the fact that you just last month
made over three grand a month
just part time from your rent to rent
plus your deal source and like that's
incredible and it's all right you know
when people come on the channel and
they're like i'm a millionaire sometimes
people can't relate to that but with
yourself doing that alongside your
full-time job yeah has it been hard time
management
yeah it has um again i think i'm in a in
a good position in comparison to some
people but i mean still yeah it's just
just putting the time into doing the
work and then moving on to property so
we're trying to get time to gym spend
time with family it's tough to do all of
it um yeah you make it work and that's
the beauty of so once you systemize the
rent to rents how much time do you spend
managing the rent to rent now probably a
lot more than i need to um
what about five hours a week an hour a
day
it's not huge no but it's it's easy from
that side because now i know but
previously to get to that point yeah
when problems creep up so it's a little
bit more maybe one week um
but yeah that's that's the other side of
it and because i know what i'm doing now
i sort of offer management so when i'm
doing the bespoke side of it i can
manage it for them or i teach them how
to manage it and stuff like that so just
work with them because at the end of the
day they'll probably be probably work
together on different things in the
future it's not just a customer sort of
trying to do it as a client um and take
it from there well bigger step bro thank
you so much all right thank you very
much
you